[Music]
so in stop sucking news hey I love to
suck on popsicles this was submitted by
Bart's ashy face is my face
ashy yes isn't it greasy not right now
it was greasy no I get that she's [ __ ]
only for like 10 seconds and my griefs
takes over it depends if it's a cold day
or not you know it's funny I get ashy
from here down to you though I don't
know why these are but joins the list of
major companies who plan to get rid of
single-use plastics for awesome I saw
this [ __ ] multi-use plans yo what's
this craze now with like no more straws
and [ __ ] I've been about terribles tell
me why I know it's gonna be put into
play Starbucks what was the question
someone answer questions why what's the
craze with the ha right he's like I feel
like back in the day it was the [ __ ]
a 6-pack plastic ring [ __ ] like that was
the big thing you know still a thing
yeah I mean you know what I do I cut
that [ __ ] every time and even if
it's not my problem but I see in the
trash not cut I [ __ ] rip that
[ __ ] open oh it's really cool
save the turtles see those anymore
like the six-pack thing maybe you don't
buy soda there we go
what is the recent thing plastic bags
they [ __ ] outlaw that [ __ ] now you
got to buy for 10 cents it's not
outlawed the free [ __ ] is it feels like
it feels like that shit's [ __ ] wrong
Europe's been doing that [ __ ] euros
buddy
it didn't really deter me I just paid 10
cents for the bag now yeah I always just
pay 10 cents well what was there like in
the back in the day
don't use paper your foot save the trees
burn the [ __ ] air instead get plastic
right that's that's what what I think
there was a transition like paper
plastic I'll go plastic it's because I
bought this huge grocery thing where you
could put a bunch of groceries up I
always forget it we have one tool and I
always forget it too so I always have to
get those bags she brings it though god
girls have really good like memory when
it comes to things that you need you
need to [ __ ] remember to take that to
so-and-so bring that [ __ ] over there man
I forget like a [ __ ] yes ask me
about some [ __ ] [ __ ] else like
history or something I know in America
we used over 500 million we use how many
500 million I was reading this I didn't
even hear why you guys are laughing it
just sounds like Joe that is all
intervention like is letting out life's
regrets it's just the plastic bag just
watch this video and you'll catch it
alright so anyway yeah so in America we
use over 500 million plastic straws
every single day now there's this
movement Strahl this or ocean org is
website where they're talking about this
challenge hashtag stop sucking and it's
pretty much where you pledge to not use
plastic straws anymore so what are we
supposed to do you have metal ones
oh you carry a straw around like a
Tweaker that strong [ __ ] dude
I had one of those in my the side of my
car right and I think we were cleaning
out my car
dating Jess she was like what is that
and I'm like oh it's just a glass straw
for like you know like so you don't use
straws and [ __ ] and she's like are you
sure I don't [ __ ] do math why she
know why she said she's been around the
box metal strong steel and silicone
straws glass straws paper straws they
want they want you to bring it with you
to go to to go to the store and you just
insert your own that's what they want or
if you're gonna use it at home you have
that yeah but then that's why Starbucks
is in this conversation because they're
gonna get rid of it and they're gonna
change their cups to like a sippy cup
type of well but it tastes different
though without a sippy cup you can have
your own straw then you can get a
plastic ball or maybe they'll have
straws that you would turn to them well
this is like a reusable one yeah there
you have it but then when you buy it
they're not gonna give you a straw you
have to bring your own custom so now by
2020 Starbucks is trying to eliminate
plastic straws globally because they
used about three million per day if you
go to Starbucks and you ask for these
lids yeah they'll give it to you so this
is like mainly for their cold drinks
that's just gonna change the game dude
yeah and so it's pretty much like these
sippy cup lids instead of what they have
now ha gotcha [ __ ] so what exactly are
the straws doing oh there's penguins
[ __ ] choking on that [ __ ] they're
saying about 71% of seabirds and 30% of
turtles have been found with plastics in
their stomachs oh I thought it was kelp
when they ingest plastic the marine life
has a 50% mortality rate people ship
mm-hmm so they're just pretty much
saying like well I mean obviously
there's a lot more you can do like you
know you can as well but this is just
like like you know what people are
focusing your honor's you know there's
like a plastic island in the middle of
the Pacific Ocean best [ __ ] just
clumped up yeah we need to get that
[ __ ] and throw it in a volcano
you know what
okay no okay no okay no that's it hey we
had an eruption in the Big Island
[ __ ] airlift that [ __ ] throw
that [ __ ] in tamela's are cracking so we
know the birds are eating straws is if
they're stupid as [ __ ] Rick what is
wrong because they're saying that straws
are the top ten items found during beach
cleanup I've never seen a CEO eat a
[ __ ] straw either if you're fighting
them then the birds aren't eating them
yeah because you're [ __ ] they have
access to them so they might be eating
the ones that you're not finding now
that you know the [ __ ] you're not fun
that's why you're only finding strong I
want to open up birds because what
Rick's argument is how do they know
what's inside the birds isn't the six
pack bean or like one of them when they
die or they open them up and they seed
straws in their microplastics but ya
know the six pack thing is part of it
too is just like yeah there are a lot of
plastic even like the disposable
utensils so the lids that they're making
yeah that's part of it too yeah why
don't we just go paper everything paper
straw paper cut paper what about the
trees Oh paper straws [ __ ] they really
do so he invented some biodegradable
[ __ ] that looks like plastic and it's
clear but then they it's biodegradable I
mean maybe it's expensive maybe like you
can't be mass-produced yet look [ __ ]
them they care so much pay extra give me
a glass cup every time you [ __ ] it's
your last straw glass turns into sand
tell me while we're running out of sand
seagulls eating glass and [ __ ] dumb
[ __ ] damn and [ __ ] dumbass seagulls
yeah but there's a lot of companies I
have pledged to not stop using straws I
bet McDonald's a one of them they
haven't yet yeah but they're trying to
cuz they use 95 million straws a day
dang I want to be that ball that's been
Starbuck I can't even afford that many
straws in one day 95 million [ __ ] dude
[ __ ] money man but yes some of the
companies at Alaska Airlines the entire
city of Seattle is straw las' plastic
strip Portland's next it would be
[ __ ] hipster ass fools
yeah next therefore does hell man the
Chicago White Sox the food service
provider Bon Appetit management company
thank goodness for people who care about
[ __ ] and they're like we got to do
something you know now over here like I
wanna [ __ ] get straws in my glass of
water cuz I it just tastes better that
way
you know I mean like when you get a
restaurant glass and you [ __ ] drink
that [ __ ] and you could taste the soap
la beche is nasty
so the straw makes the soap taste go
away yeah it does
yep you're not smelling the cup while
you're drinking yeah you're not licking
the cup yeah I drink water now you gotta
set the tongue first you got the the
tongue is like a slide it's like a ramp
it's like we're just described is not
touching the car there's a little my
tongue is behind my teeth yeah my tongue
is behind my teeth never mind I'm doing
a monkey kiss I'm gonna like this why'd
you say your tongue was a rat I thought
I thought I went like this
I thought that's all wet like I don't
know what I imagined is not what really
happens in life tell us what really
happened you know like you don't know
you don't know God lawyers worst
nightmare so what happened at the scene
of the crime this was like what would I
imagine
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]